there's just a weird vibe in that
building we hadn't done
any country award shows or anything
since the controversy
it's the highest rated 15 minutes in cma
history
and then they start getting you know
racist
bombarding their website with comments
and emails and whatever
and so they take her down they took our
performance down
and caved to that book and then
they i guess got so much bad press for
doing that
within 24 hours they put it back up
again just cowards it's just
crazy she just gave you your greatest
ratings
that you've ever gotten how dare you
take her song off
let me just say the week we worked with
beyonce is the single greatest working
week of my professional life
it was awesome the chicks are no
stranger to controversy
the trio were famously blacklisted from
country radio 17 years ago
after criticizing u.s president george w
bush
and now they're facing backlash for
recently cutting the term dixie from
their name in support of the black lives
matter movement
last night i'll watch what happens live
andy cohen asks what they thought of the
criticism
we don't really care okay
very good and he also asked the group
what they thought of taylor swift
embracing the power of her voice to
speak out on social issues
i loved her netflix documentary i don't
know if you saw it but
she had a really interesting moment
where she recalled how everyone in the
country music industry
warned her not to be like the chicks
throughout my whole career
label executives and publishers would
just say
don't be like the dixie chicks and i
loved the dixie chicks
what was your reaction to that it's good
to see her as she becomes her own woman
questioning these things and saying you
know i really do want to talk about it
i'm proud of her she's awesome